et moi je vais vous trouvez à je vais
vous parler de comment trouver sa place
grâce à la crise je vais vous raconter
d'ailleurs une petite histoire j'étais
encore assis là sur mon canapé à me
demander ce que je fais de ma vie on s'y
garer dans la main droite je viens de
raccrocher mon téléphone
les larmes coulent sur ma joue un
sentiment de tristesse battement de ces
10 août à cologne
je vais en perdre en troisième jobs en
deux ans je cherche désespérément à
joindre mes amis pour cautériser cette
plaie se vit que je ressens je suis en
pleine tempête en pleine crise
je m'en sors médiocre je ne suis pas à
la place qui derrière son ordinateur ne
s'est jamais retrouvé dans une position
similaire
cette sensation autre vie n'a pas de
sens
comme vous n'êtes pas vraiment à votre
place si je suis devant vous aujourd'hui
c'est pour parler de ce sujet c'est
qu'avant après cette histoire nous
avions après seul sou namy émotionnel et
spirituel
en neuf ans après cette perte hôtel de
sens j'ai l'immense alors d'accompagner
les personnes à reprendre le contrôle et
à bien vivre leur crise personnelle et
surtout à sallanches est dans quelque
chose qui est riche de sens pour eux
cette quête s'est traduit pour moi par
l'apprentissage d'un meilleur outil
coaching et surtout la rencontre de
personnalités une sportif olympique mans
1re scientifique
six artistes donc j'ai essayé de
comprendre et modéliser la réussite mais
je suis allé plus loin que ça en fait
j'aime modéliser leur système et ce
modèle j'avais ensuite appliqué à la
création de plusieurs entreprises mais
aussi à l'autre mais patient qui est la
natation en eau libre
il ya maintenant un peu moins deux ans
j'ai traversé la manche à la nage
ce qui est considéré comme l'everest de
la natation en eau libre muni de ce
magnifique petit slip de bain rouge qui
ici c'est le vrai d'un bonnet et d'une
paire de lunettes
en fait aujourd'hui vous l'aurez compris
une autre session c'est d'aider des
personnes à trouver leur place
trouver sa place n'est jamais facile et
demande un travail en profondeur
moi aussi en dose d'engagement pour se
mettre en action de manière quotidienne
et si on faisait de la crise une
opportunité pour ne trouver sa place la
première étape c'est d'apprendre à
détecter les crises oui donc vous en
soyez dans votre vie vous vous
rapprochez d'une crise plus tôt on la
détecte plus tôt on peut la gérer ou
arrivé à la gérer pour exercer le regard
sur des signaux avant-coureurs je vais
vous raconter l'histoire d'un client que
j'ai l'honneur d'accompagner dites vous
bien cette histoire
bah c'est peut-être déjà la vôtre vous
êtes prêts allons-y
je vais vous parler d'un mister joe
bastardi travail pour une grosse entité
qui accompagne des entreprises dans le
secteur industriel notamment la
plasturgie
si je le cite d'un point ouvrez les
guillemets il n'est pas à plaindre
il gagne bien sa vie et cela lui permet
de mettre sa famille en sécurité
il a d'ailleurs brillé tout de suite
après ses études dans un job qui
qualifierait selon lui de moyens depuis
quelques mois il a plus en plus dans la
nasse mauvais et on ressent des montées
de colère et de tresses envers la
manière dont il est manager en fait
c'est une situation banale qui évacuent
par un grand nombre de personnes
aujourd'hui elle faisons un arrêt quand
une crise interne se prépare il existe
toujours des signes avant-coureurs que
la situation ne se déclenche
vous savez cette petite voix fluette qui
on pense des questions et tu vraiment
sûr dans la revente au bout c'est
vraiment ce que tu veux faire toute ta
vie en sauvant que l'on balaie d'un
revers de synapses la fatigue physique
des problèmes de sommeil d'alimentation
la douleur peuvent des signes avant
coureurs d'une crise interne si on en
revient mr ji a au fil de notre échange
insulaire revient régulièrement sur la
table
je pense qu'il va vous parler il a envie
de se reconnecter à la nature il a
littéralement dans le coeur à chaque
fois qu'il entend parler des espèces
menacées ou encore qui envoie les
cheminées de fusionner dans lequel il va
aller travailler tous les jours ayant
dansé séance de kayak et on note avec
une inquiétude va réfaction bons
éléments incongrus pendant la saison
étant donné sa position il a vraiment
l'impression de faire partie du problème
le tout mixé par des croyants
générationnel qui ne pourrais jamais
vivre de son envie de préserver
l'environnement
avec cette crainte fondamentale donc
plus pouvoir subvenir aux besoins de sa
famille donc fort du message que nous
sommes en tant qu il a commencé à
traîner des pieds à procrastiner sur la
tâche qu'elle avait à accomplir
il commençait à rentrer dans une espèce
est dans une crise de sens dans une
crise de sens interne
cela ne vous rappelle rien
cette sidération ces passages émotionnel
complexes peuvent aussi se retrouver
dans la crise externe
je fais partie de la génération qui est
quand on est rentré dans le milieu du
travail
on a pris la crise des subprimes en 2010
en 2008 durant vallières de plein fouet
la crise sanitaire qui nous a bousculés
dans nos croyances lorsqu'on paraissait
complètement acquis en fait c'est la
douleur qui nous emmène cette perte de
repères et la fois souple et c'est la
possibilité donc pour retrouver barre
mon statut similaire on scande avions
avant cela va lui en moins sécurité lors
de plusieurs accompagnants et surtout
pas pendant plusieurs interviews j'ai pu
faire et je me suis rendu compte qu'il
ya un autre fondamental qu'il faudrait
déconstruire celui qu'il faut attendre
d'être au fond du gouffre pour pouvoir
réagir bon vivre mon fond de la crise
d'être au fond dans son canapé en train
de pleurer je suis athée été grandement
expliqué par les neuroscientifiques que
j'ai la chance d'aller d'aller
interviewer puisque notre cerveau
recherche à éviter la douleur tant qu'
on peut l'éviter
on ne mettra pas forcément mais
fondamentalement en actions donjon
souvent que lorsque l'on pourront jamais
faire autrement
alors arrêter d'attendre quelques jeux
pour quelque chose de grave nous
interpelle
qu'il soit venu par un stimulus qu'il
soit interne ou externe par cela
commençons par trois du temps et
remarqué les crédits afin commence à
être outillés et à mal connaître l'envié
la place dont on veut aller pour cela je
vous invite
à faire un travail fondamental et qui a
été un peu biaisé au fil des années
celui dont vos dons aux valeurs
personnelles
qu'est ce qu'une valeur par essence
accorder de la valeur à une chose
signifie que lequel celle ci a de
l'importance pour nous elles sont une
boussole qui nous permettent de filtrer
la manière dont on voit le monde leur
clarification peuvent vous nous
permettre d'avoir en dix ans de calme
lorsqu'ils arrivent dans crieu elles
peuvent être appliqués à nous mêmes à
des entreprises des collectivités et
damnation
d'ailleurs ce sont elles qui ont
confondu aviv des ammonites des
événements et vivre des états
émotionnels qui son plongeon indifférent
prenons le cas de la france
tout le monde connaît les valeurs de la
république liberté égalité fraternité
dans les pubs dans lequel on y vont nous
vivons ne serait-il pas différent si un
problème liberté égalité sororité ou
encore pendant des temps funeste ben le
souhait de l'occupation qui est travail
famille patrie
en fait le point est simple ce que l'on
peut remarquer ici c'est que pour le cas
de la france il ya un choix en
concertation des personnes et dans ce
cas-là d'hommes politiques qui ont fait
le choix de mots valeur donc nous
pouvons donc choisir notre et faire
vivre le nom d'autres systèmes de valeur
par rapport à ce que nous voulons faire
dans la vie cela a complètement changé
ma vision et mon rapport au monde
mais revenons à vous quelles sont vos
valeurs
quelle valeur voulez vous choisir il en
existe deux grands types celle de
finalité est celle dont royan si j'avais
la chance de pouvoir vous voir en direct
et vous poser cette question quelles
sont vos valeurs
les réponses seraient là membres la
santé l'argent la famille vont pouvoir
l'énergie elles vont faire partie du
différentes planètes de réponse parmi
celles-ci l'amour la santé
sont les valeurs de faim celle que l'on
recherche
celle qui met dans un état émotionnel
qu'on va qualifié de plutôt agréable
celle que l'on désire et qu'on va vivre
et que l'on a envie de vivre
a contrario nous avons l'argent la femme
n'en sont que des moyens monde et
rigueur pour déclencher cet état
émotionnel et se rapprocher des valeurs
d'un finalité dont je viens de parler
vous l'aurez compris votre job et
comprendre votre système de valeurs 200
dans le choisir nous sommes très souvent
occupés à poursuivre des valeurs de
moyens sans jamais atteindre leurs
objectifs sous j'attends c'est à dire 7
de la fin quel choix de valeurs de faim
voulez-vous faire et à voir pour vous de
quelles valeurs avec vos besoins pour
réaliser certains de vos objectifs
car comme la france et les personnes en
politique à l'époque
vous pouvez choisir votre système
comment savoir si vous vivez en dualité
de valeur et bien à chaque fois qu'on
ressent un sentiment ou l'émotion
désagréable qui ne fait pas jamais
ressenti rejetée par un groupe qu'elle
dollars ça l'a ébranlé chez vous est ce
que vous verrez un afflux de stress
quand votre boss ou vos supérieurs vous
a appelé alors que peut-être à votre
valeur dans liberté est au coeur de
votre système
ou encore d'avoir peur de l'échec
lorsqu'on a décidé de lancer en boîte ou
d'en lancer quelque chose
voici un moyen simple de reconnaître
ladjali tkip exister entre les valeurs
parce qu'en observant est programmé pour
nous inviter la douleur et va parfois
utilisé des stratagèmes alambiqué
pourront pas vivre lorgeou l'échec ou
encore de passer à l'acte
si on revient juste quelques secondes à
mr jean et dans le foie qu'il a
conscientisé ces valeurs qu'il a pu
prendre des décisions courageuses pour
rectifier la trajectoire hilarion pris
un job
vous savez quoi il a repris un job dans
l'industrie mais cette fois sur la
thématique de l'énergie au volant de la
bhl il a fait le choix en conscience de
balle est allée là où ils voulaient
voter ses valeurs les plus profondes
pour cela il a dû affronter sa crise
intérieure et retravailler ses
contradictions
une des conditions réussite est vraiment
se mettre en face des réalités est
rentré dans cette zone plutôt
désagréable un système de valeurs non
touche parce qu'en voulant posséder mais
un sujet supérieurs à ce que nous
voulons être
qui voulez-vous être qu'ils vont à vous
de venir comment ces valeurs c'est bien
s'y conformer c'est un petit peu plus
difficile
je vais vous donner un outil pour garder
le cap pendant ces périodes de crise
puisque passer à l'acte est l'un des
exercices les plus salutaire pour
trouver sa place
que ce soit sous un format de rêve
d'objectifs d'ambition dans le vie
l'autre versant de la crise et qu'elle
peut cristalliser nos émotions et
qu'elles peuvent très facilement dans ce
cas les rosés nous céder au sol où l'on
met dans une situation de stress plutôt
intense je vais vous dévoiler une
technique qu'un jamais en place pour
retrouver la sérénité et me retrouver
dans un état de concentration maximale
lors de mon passage à l'action
cette technique retenez le bien c'est le
mlr slr
pour comprendre des preuves de la
traversée de la manche
cela correspond à peu près à 42 km dans
une eau à 16 degrés est ma time inc de
démarrage et aux alentours de deux
heures du matin ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir apprendre à nager dans le noir
ce qui correspond pour un nageur de mon
calibre à peu près 14 heures réunion de
luxe dans une eau à 16 degrés vous
l'aurez bien compris pour cela il m'a
fallu un très gros niveau d'engagement
lors de cette année et demi de
préparation
il m'a fallu avaler mais 300 kilomètres
d'entraînement prend plus de 200 d'un
froid dans le réseau à 10 degrés pendant
30 minutes
et par dessus un marché mais baissière
de 7 kilos de graisse complémentaires
pour me protéger du froid
en fait l'engagement quotidien c'est la
clé de la réussite
croyez-moi va pas toujours été aussi
rose que je fus l'ex que je peux
l'exprimer en fait pour habituer encore
froid je m'en suis ont essayé la
pratique que je pratique toujours qui
s'appelle ice soit ming c'est de l'eau
qui oscille entre 0,1 et 5 degrés
imaginez vous il est 5h30 du matin vous
n'en sortez de vos plis tout chaud et
vous devez vous allez vous jeter dans un
lac qui fait d'un degré une série
d'arguments légitime bas peuvent venir
vous frapper avant vous mettre à l'eau
et aux négociations commencent dans
votre cerveau mais pourquoi tu es là
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
tu étais pas dans le dans ton lit cette
négociation peut être contre-productive
alors qu'il en faut passer à l'action
alors j'utilise la technique du fln dès
que la sensation est la première
négociation arrive tu aurais pas dû lui
est la première phrase effet retard
laisse passer
et respire je vais vous l'expliquer lors
de l'épreuve à la fin c'est j'ai eu mon
médius qui est d'en faire un bisou sur
le visage plutôt urticants et enfin elle
est plutôt venue - lacéré le visage à
deux reprises je commence à m'énerver
je commence à me demander pourquoi je
suis là et je commence à perdre dans
l'énergie et les têtes flou dans lequel
j'en suis et négociations commencent à
arriver dans ma tête
dès que la négociation commence je la
coupe directement en disant ferme tard
j'utilise cette violence verbale
parce que ça me permet de couper court
aux tergiversations qui peuvent bloquer
à certains moments ensuite emprunts à la
méditation que je pratique je laisse pas
c'est la pensée parce qu'on peut avoir
dans la vie et de pensée qui doivent
venir en contradiction avec ce que nous
voulons faire et la dernière c'est
respire
parce que la respiration permet de me
remettre dans de la concentration
cette petite technique va vous permettre
en chose fondamentale vont être à
l'action et d'avoir un esprit de claire
cette tricherie claire et 12e conditions
pour prendre des choix salutaire lors
d'une crise dans tout en pleurs
quelles qu'elles soient alors à chaque
fois que vous devez vous mettre en
action
fl eurs à chaque fois que vous commencez
à débattre si vous devez tenter
l'aventuré entreprenariale ou faire un
premier petit paquet d'appeler un client
flr pour vous devez commencer à ou à
passer un coup de téléphone à une
personne qui vous impressionne flr car
qu'est ce qui va se passer si on ne sait
pas si on prend pas son petit pain cette
petite action
elle va être repoussé hollande où l'on
va se repousser en son nom en année est
très souvent se transformer en regrets
cette simple technique m'a permis on a
préservé du bardage mentale leurs abords
hamon
objectif et m'a permis de me mettre en
action dans manière quasi quotidienne et
ce qui m'a permis de réaliser l'un des
mes rêves est l'un de mes objectifs
on fonctionne à chaque moment où nous
habitons alors que ce soit par la
clarification de notre système de
valeurs ou encore l'outil du flnc cet
alignement qui m'a permis de faire des
choix en conscience et en connaissance
de cause car il ya plusieurs façons de
prendre en compte une crise qu'elle soit
interne ou qu'elles soient extrêmes la
subir et se faire maltraiter par
l'actualité ou d'en rester sclérosé sur
son canapé
la fuir on se met des oeillères en
utilisant des distractions je peux vous
en donner un paquet donc j'ai des séries
de manière outrancière
on va voir l'arrêté en face de passer
son temps à blâmer les autres nous
prendre ses responsabilités dans son
champ alors quelles petites actions vous
pouvez aujourd'hui faire en utilisant le
faire sont autorisés de prendre sa
puissance intérieure
c'est ce qui va vous permettre de
prendre la pleine mesure de ce que nous
voulons si j'avais un message à faire
passer à vous et surtout un jeune homme
qui pleuvent sur son canapé il ya neuf
ans après s'être fait virer de son
troisième job je dirais d'embrasser ses
larmes d'embrasser la crise douce levé
commencé à créer à produire à tenter car
en fait il serait étonnant de ce qu'il
peut accomplir de manière imparfaite en
neuf ans nous mêmes en démarrant en
étant au fond du beauf en étant au fond
de son canapé parce que la cré m
l'inconfort ce qu'une trame elle sculpte
aux autres êtres car pour trouver sa
place
en fait l'intelligence réside dans la
manière de réagir aux choses et de se
mettre en action
mon plus beau cadeau que vous
vous faire et de vivre en adéquation
avec vos valeurs merci